ben swan journaliste d'investigation
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir bonsoir ben soit merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
fermeture des frontières pour tous ceux
qui ne sont pas citoyens ou résidents
américains
pas étonnant quand on connaît un petit
peu la politique de donald trump comment
ça a été accueilli aux états unis a été
perçue très différemment en fonction
d'élu mieux politique c'est comme ça la
part du temps dans ce pays donne un
train a dit qu'il souhaitait interrompre
toute immigration tout quelques endroits
que ce soit non seulement de la chine
une goutte de l'europe et il ya une
raison pour cela et je vais développer
plus tard que il s'agit de faire la cour
aux travailleurs et ceux où les grands
prennent des emplois alors que beaucoup
d'américains on sent maintenant au
chômage donc que les démocrates les
personnes à gauche sont contre cette
idée et les personnes à droite
les partisans de trump sont des parties
sont pour
et puis il ya ensuite les indépendants
les voteurs qui ne votent pas pour des
parties thématiques mans et de ce point
de vue là ça dépend de là où ils
prennent leurs informations parce que
des gens disent c'est une très mauvaise
idée de ces jeunes quand on sait qu'il
ya des millions à 22 millions
d'américains qui ont perdu leur emploi
qu'on est à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
est ce que cette carte identitaire n'est
pas la meilleure chose
finalement c'est la provocation mais
question mais enfin vous pouvez faire
donald trump dans ce contexte
électoralement parlant bien sûr je pense
que toutes les stratégies sont
politiques en ce moment et c'est vrai au
congrès
chez les démocrates que je vais y
arriver car effectivement le président
mène sa campagne dont il doit être
certain que toutes ces décisions sont
bonnes pour ses électeurs et que les
haters soit content de ce que fait le
président de ce qu'il gère donc c'est
pour cela qu'il faut que les personnes
qui protestent contre les le confinement
dans beaucoup d'états ont dit à ses
lecteurs vous voulez travailler les
gouverneurs devrait vous écoutez ce
n'est peut-être pas forcément le
meilleur conseil mais en tout cas cela
mais le président du côté du peuple et
non pas du côté du gouvernement
c'est très inhabituel de voir un
président qui se passe à côté de jeunes
plutôt que à côté du 1 logement du
gouvernement qui dirige donc c'est
nouveau mais on va voir ce que ça donne
effectivement donald trump qui a une
façon bien à lui de gérer cette crise du
corps d'un virus a été l'un des premiers
à fermer ses frontières maintenant ils
poussent certains états républicains à
ceux des confiné allant à l'encontre
d'ailleurs des gouverneurs poussant même
les gens allaient manifester commencé
perçu outre atlantique ces décisions
parce qu'on sait qu'en ce moment les
manifester c'est pas forcément la bonne
idée en termes de distanciation sociale
effectivement les manifestations on est
pas au niveau de la distanciation
sociale mais il ya beaucoup de questions
concernant l'efficacité de ces mesures
la question la plus importante reste
économique et je veux pas dire que le
strict où les grandes entreprises
c'est à ce à quoi pensent certaines
personnes mais je parle des petits
propriétaires ceux qui n'ont pas de
salaire qui n'ont pas de salaire depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines qu'ils
attendent encore les aides
gouvernementales
ces personnes sont très inquiètes niveau
de l'économie s'ils demandent ce qui va
se passer à l'avenir
à l'avenir très proche que nous
assistons à un mécontentement
grandissant 30 à 35 % des américains
jolie feinte illégale du confinement
c'est à une deux ou trois semaines et
pourrait y avoir encore plus de
mécontentement et on pourrait imaginer
que beaucoup de personnes changent
d'opinions 15h et du manioc raymond
famille ben swan comment cette crise du
coronavirus pestel dans cette campagne
de l'élection présidentielle on rappelle
un cent quatre-vingt dix sept jours
avant l'élection ses prises de décisions
de donald trump mais aussi on imagine
une campagne des républicains des
pardons des démocrates assez inaudibles
sétif je pense que nous ayons un moment
de campagne le président organise des
conférences de presse mais il essaye de
se positionner comme dirigeant déterminé
ce n'est pas vraiment une véritable
campagne il n'a pas pu se rendre dans
les états comme d'habitude et joe barton
qui est le candidat démocrate essaye de
tenir des réunions depuis sa cave de
puissants s'il y a un côté positif pour
le peuple américain c'est qu'on n'est
pas obligé de me voir infliger une
campagne en profondeur elle est un peu
équipe s'est mise de côté
peut-être qu'au cours des semaines et
des mois à venir il y aura une véritable
campagne mais pour le moment il ya une
sorte de calme et c'est très positif
la plupart des gens en ce moment on ne
veulent pas entendre parler de politique
ils veulent tendre
ils veulent savoir ce que le
gouvernement veut faire pour les aider
merci beaucoup bonne soit une
journaliste d'investigation d'avoir été
avec nous dans vu de l'extérieur ce soir